before we get to today's episode we'd
just like to give a huge
shout out to our sponsor squarespace
[Music]
have you ever heard of the raw meat diet
that's right a diet that consists of
eating raw meat
all day every day most of us
have been taught to avoid raw meat like
it's the plague
but is it really that bad for you
these people seem to be doing all right
i guess
what would be the best way to eat raw
meat
how would it affect your body
and what are the benefits of this diet
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you only ate raw meat
people on the raw meat diet say that
they eat it for health reasons because
it's more nutritious after all some
studies suggest
that the process of cooking meat may
reduce the content
of certain vitamins and minerals other
raw meat enthusiasts report having more
energy and a boost in sex drive
but none of this is supported by
overwhelming evidence
and even if it were would the good
effects
outweigh all the bad ones there's only
one way to find out
let's give it a try
before we get into the effects that an
all raw meat diet would have
on your body let's look at how you would
eat it
in the first place you would have to cut
up the raw meat into small
bite-sized pieces human teeth struggle
to break down raw meat
they're almost useless we don't have the
sharp
canine teeth to chop and slice through
raw meat
our teeth are meant for grinding food if
you were to bite a piece of raw game
you would struggle to chew it it would
be like
gum and you'd just be chewing forever
it doesn't get any better once you
swallow it because
eating raw meat can do long-term damage
to your body
i don't know about you but i can sure go
for some cooked meat right about now
[Music]
let's be honest though raw meat versus
cooked meat
i know what i'm picking i love the
barbecue too much
in fact i'm making some beef jerky right
now let's go look
you can't smell this but it's the smell
of beef and smoke
it's hickory smoke and it's uh eye of
the round that i'm making oh my god
there it is
and it looks like it's just about done
so i'll make this quick
um i make really good beef jerky if i do
say so myself and i've made so much of
it over the years
and uh people tend to really like it
that i actually thought about going into
business with it
starting full-time jerky business this
is no lie um
but i'm not going to i'm uh going to
keep doing
the what if series voice of what if but
i did
go ahead and make my own little beef
jerky website
there it is the best beef jerky you will
ever eat and that
is no lie i wish you could taste it i'm
uh sorry i can't give it to you you know
millions of people are now looking for
extra ways to make cash or maybe even
starting new businesses of their own
going out uh making maybe making their
own beef jerky business well
one thing i would suggest if you are
starting your business is
do a website of your own i would suggest
using squarespace
the sponsor of this video not only does
squarespace have industry-leading
designs it's also got a whole bunch of
tools that
help make your life easy whether it's
their blogging tools or their workflow
tools
one thing that stood out for me was
their social media integration
content you post on your website can
instantly be sent out to twitter or
facebook
but one of the cooler things about
squarespace is how easy they make it to
help sell weekly or monthly
subscriptions
think about it jerky is a month club huh
think about subscriptions
it's recurring monthly revenue or weekly
revenue
anyways it's a no-brainer try it out go
to squarespace.com
and build your website for free when
you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com what if and use
the promo code
what if to get 10 off your first domain
or website
yeah i could talk about barbecue and
smoked meat
all day long but that's not what's on
the menu today
instead we have this raw meat
not only does it not look as appealing
as cooked meat but
it can also cause you a lot of trouble
undercooked or raw meat and poultry can
be contaminated with harmful bacteria
such as e coli salmonella and yersinia
if there are bacteria in the meat it can
make you
really sick usually this includes
diarrhea
stomach cramps vomiting and a fever
and if you feel fine after eating your
first raw meat dish
well just wait a little bit before
passing judgment
after you've eaten the bacteria it can
take up to 24 hours to experience
symptoms
and they can last for many days
depending on the type of bacteria
if you still want to proceed with the
diet
you'll need to be careful of what kind
of meat you'll be putting in your body
you might want to stay away from chicken
because it tends to contain
more harmful bacteria like salmonella
since
chicken has a more porous structure it's
easier for bacteria to penetrate
deep into the meat that's the reason why
when you're cooking chicken
you can't just sear the surface to kill
all the pathogens
also to reduce your chances of eating
bacteria filled meat
you should only eat locally sourced and
organic meats that have not been
overly processed and that would quickly
start to get
really expensive but according to raw
meat enthusiasts
it would all be worth it they say that
once your body gets used to eating raw
meat
you'll get a lot more nutrients and
protein than you would from
the cooked alternatives in one serving
of raw ground beef
you get a whole 17 grams of protein
however there is such a thing as too
much protein
research shows that eating more than two
grams of protein
per kilogram of body weight daily can
cause symptoms of dehydration
nausea irritability headache and
indigestion
it can also increase your risk of severe
health problems such as
cardiovascular disease liver and kidney
injuries and
even death so maybe spending your days
eating raw meat isn't the best idea
if you're going to go for a raw diet
it's best to also include raw vegetables
and to get nutrients from other foods
instead of
just raw meat it's also important to
note that
just because our ancestors did something
a certain way
doesn't mean that we have to can you
imagine if we
all lived our lives like we were
neanderthals
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]